made a point a few minutes ago about how
um if a woman doesn't feel secure with a
man she's going to do
um x y z to feel secure or just leave I
I think they're I think women have
shifted to where they've are doing stuff
on their own doing stuff that men
usually would so when a man comes in and
does that for them they're like I don't
need you to do that for me I can do that
on my own show me something else that
you can do for me to for me to have you
in my life for me to have you in that
place and a man's like well I'm doing
what I am supposed to do but I'm not
able to do it because you're doing it as
well and you're not being in your
femininity for me to be able to show you
that I am doing the manly thing I need
to do so women are like oh he's not this
he's not that because he's not doing it
and it's like how can you have someone
do something for you if you're not
giving them room enough to do it to be
them and it's not it's not comfortable
for them to do it I think I would say
this I think that a lot of women like I
do get where you're coming from I think
that a lot of women don't trust men but
the reason why a lot of women in these
days like modern women don't trust men
is because they didn't have a dad so if
you didn't have a dad initially in the
foundation yeah and then probably you've
just seen your mum struggle get money do
everything by yourself then she's
probably taught you just oh you know
what do it by yourself don't ever depend
on a man yeah obviously you're never
gonna trust a man because the first man
in your life wasn't there he he failed
you yeah you know what I'm saying and I
think but then if you go deeper into
that I think that happens because a lot
of times women make poor choices in men
and so like I don't really want to say
oh it's all women's for or it's all
mental but we have to be realistic in
this thing in it to get them said
um and yeah I agree with what Jess said
you know women women out here are doing
more for themselves and that's that that
boils down to like over consumerism
because women spend the most money they
they they're looking at Instagram oh
look at that car look at them shoes look
at that bag I want that so they will go
with the extra mile to getting things
but then when they come across a guy who
may be the right guy for them but may
not be able to buy all those things
that's when the conflict comes you know
what I'm saying that's when oh I only
want to date a guy that's gonna take me
to hakasan another cough and them kind
of things but them kind of guys bro
they're just gonna use you bro so again
that's more poor choices then the more
poor choices you make the more baggage
you get the more better you become and
then brother like you're done because at
some point you probably become a baby
mama at some point and then the guys
that you like don't want to don't want
nothing no commitment with you they just
want to use you and the cycle continues
and then you bring another generation
that does the same thing no I agree
you've got a point I agree I I think
like um women definitely do make poor
choices in men but um the quality of men
have kind of gone down I really think
it's the women but I think so in in just
regards to like you said the father
wasn't there this wasn't there but I
think sometimes people have to take
accountability like you said I totally
agree about taking poor choices but once
something has happened to part of being
a man is finding Solutions you
understand and rectifying certain things
so you see like like if you have a child
or something and it might not have been
the ideal situation but it's now your
responsibility to you know to be a good
father to your children do you
understand what I mean yeah so therefore
they're not going to grow up with as
much Daddy Issues not just leave them
well I think that's the women's fault
though like yeah because they picked
them like why are you sleeping with him
why are you letting him like why aren't
you on birth control we have 41 forms of
birth control pick one
and like why are you why are you letting
a bat a guy that would be a bad dad get
you pregnant like that that's stupid
like what you can't change men and like
as women I think innately we know who's
gonna stick around we know who isn't so
why would you pick him and really and
truly it's a small percentage of guys
that are out here making baby making
machines bro it's a small percentage bro
it's the guys that the guys that
aesthetically look like Derek Jackson
Rev
do you get what I'm saying like the guy
the the five foot five guy is not the
one that's causing all the problems out
here it's not bro it's the six foot
three six foot fire for like Charming
guy
do you get what I'm saying that is
causing the problem so reading truly bro
it comes down to girls because initially
it's the woman who chooses do you get
what I'm saying and the women typically
leave too like like because the The
Narrative is that like men are the one
sleeping and we can't trust men because
they might leave but women leave more
than men do I was gonna say as well like
I mean I think because you were in a
divorce court or a divorce yes a major
major reason why I see that women are
you know men have pretty much stayed the
same in terms of very not simple and
derogative way but the very basic stuff
you know not have high standards of what
a woman should bring but um
women have gone to universities got
degrees and you know all that stuff
in in recent years so that has been a
major factor in them thinking oh you
know what I could do better and that's
where hypergamy comes in
women have never had the skills like to
this level ever before and where men
have kind of stayed the same you know
they're they're the Breadwinners but now
when the woman can out earn him
naturally she'll be like oh I could do
better than him like what can he offer
me and that's really unfair because is
that his worth like just what he can
offer financially if the children are
eating the children are fed it like
bathe closed so when she gets too
comfortable with you know what then she
starts thinking well I could just if I
can out earn him like what do I need him
for
um whether that's good or bad is
something else but then she has that
mentality because
yeah I think that's the main reason why
women you can see the change that women
have made men have stayed the same you
got you got chicks that are doing only
fans yeah selling their body online
making a lot of money because of Sims
again and then obviously even they will
have higher expectations because they oh
I'm making 10 racks a month so you know
I need to be with a guy that makes x
amount bro like it just kind of messes
up the whole game yeah like women are
looking down on nine to five yeah
can't win I've done so many reaction
videos to women saying ah nah if a guy
does 95 he they would rather they'd
actually rather date a criminal a
scammer yes then date a guy that does
nine to five because oh if I just want
to go to Italy at the drop of a hat he
can't do that he has to ask his boss and
yeah I need a guy that's an entrepreneur
or a scammer bro this is unrealistic
boss I've seen too many videos like that
yeah
five in the UK and the USA this is
normal stuff do you think guys like
Derek Jackson know what they're doing
absolutely yeah yeah
I'm so tired they're they're Jackson is
hitting a target audience and the
majority of them are black women and he
knows that if I can get them I have them
hooked and it's sad to say but they're
going to
keep going because I'm not sure if this
stat is correct but I think that the
highest like unmarried demographic is
um one of the highest I'll say one of
the highest is black woman and he knows
that if I
what he's saying is it as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
demonetized on a daily
form it
considered sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible